If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the rest is history.com and click gifts. This episode is sponsored by Hive. Britain revolutionised the future with the might of industrial power. But now you can transform your own energy future and take control with the power of Hive. Hive makes the most of the sun, with solar panels turning sunlight into greener electricity and enabling you to sell excess back to the grid. And Hive's thermostats make it possible
如果您想了解更多节目内容，请加入“历史即一切”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）。随着圣诞节临近，您也可以为您生活中的历史爱好者赠送一整年的会员资格。只需前往therestishistory.com并点击“礼物”即可。本期节目由Hive赞助。英国曾以强大的工业力量彻底改变了未来。但现在，您可以利用Hive的力量来改变自己的能源未来并掌握主动权。Hive充分利用太阳能，通过太阳能电池板将阳光转化为更环保的电力，并使您能够将多余的电力卖回电网。而Hive的恒温器让您
for you to heat your home without lifting anything more than a thumb and an impressed brow. Their heat pumps draw warmth from the air and they keep it exactly where you want it. No smoke, no waste. Hive's EV charger. your car charge quietly overnight. Recharging while you do too. Hive brings it all together. Heating, charging and solar managed from one simple app in a quiet revolution. In the long history of power, Hive helps you finally know yours. Head to hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected technology. Paid for surplus requires
无需动一根手指，甚至无需皱一下眉头，就能调节家中的温度。他们的热泵从空气中汲取热量，并将其精确地保持在您想要的温度。没有烟雾，没有浪费。Hive的电动汽车充电器让您的汽车在夜间安静地充电，在您休息的同时完成充电。Hive将这一切融为一体。供暖、充电和太阳能管理都通过一个简单的应用程序实现，这是一场安静的革命。在漫长的能源史上，Hive帮助您最终掌握自己的能源。前往hivehome.com了解更多信息。需视勘测和适用性而定。Hive应用程序兼容特定技术。出售剩余电力需要
SEG tariff. Some of the reported clues must be received with caution. No end of
SEG关税。一些报道的线索必须谨慎对待。无穷无尽的
stories are rife in the neighbourhood told with an air of circumstantiality which on examination proves to be utterly baseless. Almost the
故事在邻里间流传，讲述时煞有介事，但经调查却发现完全毫无根据。几乎
sole testimony which seems to have any bearing on the affair is that given by a young woman named Pannier who sells roasted chestnuts at the corner of Widegate Street, a narrow thoroughfare, about two minutes walk from the crime. Mrs Pannier is reported to have stated that shortly afternoon yesterday, a man, dressed like a gentleman, said to her, I suppose you've heard about the murder in Dorset Street, and when she replied
唯一似乎与此案有关的证词，是一位名叫潘尼尔（Pannier）的年轻女子提供的，她在怀特盖特街（Widegate Street）的拐角处卖烤栗子，那是一条距离案发地点步行约两分钟的狭窄通道。据报道，潘尼尔夫人称，昨天下午一点过后，一名打扮得像绅士的男子对她说：“我想你已经听说多塞特街（Dorset Street）发生的谋杀案了吧。”当她回答
that she was aware of it, he said, I know more about it than you. He then proceeded down Sandy's Row, a narrow thoroughfare which cuts across Widegate Street. Street looking back as if to see whether he was watched. Mrs. Penaier described this person as a man about five foot six inches high with a black mustache and wearing a black silk hat, dark coat and speckled trousers. He carried a black shiny bag about 18 inches long and a foot deep. It will be remembered that this description agrees fairly well with a personage previously described and that the black bag has more than once figured in the evidence given. So that was the Daily Telegraph on the 10th of November 1888.
说她知道这件事时，他说：“我知道的比你多。”随后，他沿着桑迪巷（Sandy's Row）走去，那是一条横穿怀特盖特街的狭窄通道。他边走边回头，仿佛在看是否有人跟踪。潘尼尔夫人描述此人身高约五英尺六英寸，留着黑色胡须，戴着黑色丝绸礼帽，穿着深色外套和斑点长裤。他提着一个黑色闪亮的包，长约18英寸，深一英尺。人们会记得，这个描述与之前描述的人物相当吻合，而且那个黑色的包不止一次出现在证据中。以上就是1888年11月10日的《每日电讯报》。
It was following up its reports on a hideous discovery made the day before in Miller's Court, which was a small paved yard off Dorset Street in Spittelfields. Now we finished our previous episode in Miller's Court, number 13, with a terrible discovery. But just before we get into that discovery, let's talk a bit about Miller's Court and Dorset Street, Tom, because Dorset Street was notorious, wasn't it, as probably the worst street in London? Yes, that is its reputation. And Miller's Court was one of a number of yards that kind of stretched off Dorset Street that had helped to give it that reputation.
它在跟进报道前一天在米勒庭院（Miller's Court）发现的一起骇人听闻的案件，米勒庭院是多塞特街旁的一个铺着路面的小院子，位于斯皮塔佛德（Spitalfields）。我们上一集在米勒庭院13号结束时，提到了一个可怕的发现。但在我们深入探讨那个发现之前，汤姆，我们先聊聊米勒庭院和多塞特街，因为多塞特街臭名昭著，不是吗？它大概是伦敦最糟糕的街道？是的，这就是它的名声。而米勒庭院是多塞特街延伸出的众多院落之一，正是这些院落助长了它的恶名。
And since the layout of Miller's Court is quite important to understanding the, episodes that we're going to be describing in the next 20 or so minutes. Let's give a description of it. So Miller's Court is accessed by a narrow covered alley that leads off Dorset Street into what had once been a garden, but has since been lined on either side of the walls of the garden with dilapidated two-story buildings. So it is very claustrophobic, it's very airless, and even by day it is shrouded in a kind of stigian gloom. There are three privies that are set against the back wall. So you probably don't want to be caught short in the middle of the night.
由于米勒庭院的布局对于理解我们接下来二十分钟左右要描述的情节非常重要，我们先来描述一下它。米勒庭院通过一条狭窄的带顶棚的小巷进入，这条小巷从多塞特街通向曾经的花园，但后来花园两侧被破旧的两层建筑所包围。所以这里非常幽闭，空气不流通，即使在白天也笼罩在一种冥河般的阴暗中。后墙边有三个厕所。所以你可能不想在半夜里急着上厕所。
There is also a single gas lamp next to where the covered passageway from Dorset Street joins the yard. So if you come out from that covered passageway by night, it will be dark, but you will step out into a kind of flickering light from the gas lamp. And that means that anyone who is emerging from the passageway, you know, people who are looking out from one of the windows, you know, the upper windows around the garden, they would be able to see whoever was stepping out of the passageway. If that person has stepped out of the passageway and he then turns sharp right,
在多塞特街的带顶棚通道连接院子的地方旁边，还有一盏单头煤气灯。所以如果你晚上从那个带顶棚的通道出来，外面会很黑，但你会步入煤气灯闪烁的光亮中。这意味着任何从通道出来的人，你知道，那些从窗户往外看的人，你知道，花园周围的上层窗户，他们都能看到任何从通道走出来的人。如果那个人走出了通道，然后猛地向右转，
he will then be confronted by a locked door. And this door in turn leads into number third. Miller's Court and it is a converted parlor, so just a single room and it's 10 feet by 12 feet, so not large at all. It's a very sparsely furnished. There's a bed, there's a table, there's a chair, there's a washstand, there's a cupboard. There is also a fireplace and hung over the fireplace. There is a cheap print, the fisherman's widow. Now, the person renting this room is a young woman, probably around 25 years old. And Dominant, you introduced us to her at the end of the last episode. She is called Mary Jane Kelly. And she owes her landlord 29 shillings,
他就会面对一扇锁着的门。这扇门通往米勒庭院13号，它是一个改造过的客厅，只有一个房间，10英尺乘12英尺，一点也不大。家具非常简陋。有一张床、一张桌子、一把椅子、一个洗脸架、一个橱柜。还有一个壁炉，壁炉上挂着一张廉价的印刷画《渔夫的遗孀》。现在，租这个房间的人是一位年轻女子，大概25岁左右。多米尼克，你在上一集结尾向我们介绍了她。她叫玛丽·简·凯利（Mary Jane Kelly）。她欠房东29先令，
which is equivalent to six weeks rent. So she owes a lot. She's badly in arrears. And we heard in our previous episode, how on the morning of the 9th of November 1888, her landlord, a shopkeeper called John McCarthy, whose shop directly abuts the passageway that leads into Miller's court. So his shop is looking out onto Dorset Street and then the sidewall is part of what forms the passageway that leads into Miller's court. He's decided that, you know, six weeks back rent. Yeah. He needs the money. It's time that she coughed up. And as you mentioned again in the previous episode, it's the day of the Lord's Mayer's show and McCarthy is clearly anxious that Mary Jane might be going off to see the show. She talked about how she was looking forward to it and he wants
相当于六周的房租。所以她欠了很多钱。她严重拖欠房租。我们在上一集听到，1888年11月9日早上，她的房东，一个名叫约翰·麦卡锡（John McCarthy）的店主，他的店直接紧邻通往米勒庭院的通道。所以他的店面朝多塞特街，侧墙是形成通往米勒庭院通道的一部分。他决定，你知道，六周的房租。是的。他需要钱。是时候让她付钱了。正如你在上一集再次提到的，那天是市长巡游日（Lord Mayor's Show），麦卡锡显然很担心玛丽·简可能会去看巡游。她谈到她很期待，而他想
to get the money out of her before she can go off and spend it on all the kind of festivities. But obviously Mary Jane is never going to get to the Lord May's show. And in fact, a shadow is going to be cast over the Lord Mayor's show. This day will not be remembered for the Lord Mayor parading through the streets of the city of London. it will be remembered for unspeakable scene of horror. John McCarthy, the shopkeeper, had sent his young assistant, Thomas Boyer, to knock on Mary James Lock Door. And as you described in the previous episode, he had seen something horrific.
在她把钱花在各种庆祝活动之前把钱要回来。但显然玛丽·简永远不会去参加市长巡游了。事实上，市长巡游将蒙上一层阴影。这一天不会因为市长在伦敦城街道上的巡游而被铭记，它将因为一场无法言说的恐怖场景而被铭记。店主约翰·麦卡锡派了他的年轻助手托马斯·博耶（Thomas Boyer）去敲玛丽·简锁着的门。正如你在上一集所描述的，他看到了可怕的一幕。
And by the late morning, this is bringing police personnel crowding into Miller's Court. So they're coming into Dorset Street, they're crowding down that narrow alleyway, and they're filling this kind of squalid, cramped space. They're joined by the local police surgeon, Dr. Phillips, the Baxter, who we've been meeting periodically throughout this series. He has got there by 1115, and 15 minutes later, he is joined by Inspector Abiline. Now, the door is locked, and you might think that there was a certain degree of urgency about breaking into the room.
到了上午晚些时候，警察开始涌入米勒庭院。他们来到多塞特街，挤进那条狭窄的小巷，填满了这个肮脏、狭窄的空间。当地警医菲利普斯医生（Dr. Phillips）也加入了进来，还有我们在本系列中不时提到的巴克斯特（Baxter）。他在11点15分到达，15分钟后，阿伯莱恩督察（Inspector Abiline）也到了。现在，门是锁着的，你可能会认为破门而入有一定的紧迫性。
However, Phillips advises Abiline to wait for the bloodhounds to arrive. Dominic, you were talking about the bloodhouse. Barnaby and Bergo or whatever they're called. Yeah. Yeah. And he's saying, well, you know, we don't want to go in and have human contact, disturb it. The dogs will be able to track down the killer if we leave it shut.
然而，菲利普斯建议阿伯莱恩等待猎犬到来。多米尼克，你之前谈到了猎犬。巴纳比（Barnaby）和伯戈（Bergo）什么的。是的。他说，好吧，你知道，我们不想进去接触现场，破坏它。如果我们保持门锁着，狗就能追踪到凶手。
And so Abiline does as advised. But as you said, this plan for using the bloodhounds has kind of fallen through and their owner has decided to take them to a dog show instead. So the bloodhounds never turn up. And finally, by half-past-one in the afternoon, Abilene has had enough of waiting. And so he orders the door to be forced. And John McCarthy, he gets a pickaxe and he smashes the door in. Now, what do they find inside?
于是阿伯莱恩照做了。但正如你所说，这个使用猎犬的计划落空了，它们的主人决定带它们去参加狗展。所以猎犬从未出现。最后，到了下午一点半，阿伯莱恩已经等得不耐烦了。于是他下令破门。约翰·麦卡锡拿了一把镐，把门砸开了。那么，他们在里面发现了什么？
They find that Mary Jane's clothes are neatly folded on the chair. In the fireplace, there rather remains still of a fire that had clearly been so hot that it had burnt off the handle and spout of a tin kettle that had been placed next to the fireplace. And lying on the bed is a body so hideously, so grotesquely mutilated, that Dr. Phillips, when he spoke at the subsequent inquest, opted to suppress the full horror of the details. Yeah. And it's only in 1987 that a set of notes came to light
他们发现玛丽·简的衣服整齐地叠在椅子上。壁炉里还有火的余烬，火显然烧得太旺，以至于烧掉了放在壁炉旁的一个锡水壶的把手和壶嘴。床上躺着一具被极其残忍、极其怪诞地肢解的尸体，以至于菲利普斯医生在随后的调查中选择隐瞒了细节的全部恐怖。是的。直到1987年，才有一套笔记重见天日，
that had been compiled by a second doctor, Thomas Bond, who also attended the murder scene that morning. He'd arrived shortly after the door had been forced. And he was very experienced in conducting post-mortems, and he recorded details in very kind of spare clinical prose. And I will read from it now, But we've been issuing the warnings throughout this series that the details of the mutilations are horrific. And one of the things that people who've listened to them may have noticed is that the mutilations become more and more hideous as each murder is committed.
那是第二位医生托马斯·邦德（Thomas Bond）编写的，他也于那天早上到达了谋杀现场。他在破门后不久就到了。他在进行尸检方面非常有经验，他用非常简洁的临床语言记录了细节。我现在要读一下，但我们在整个系列中一直在发出警告，肢解的细节是可怕的。听过这些的人可能已经注意到，随着每一桩谋杀案的发生，肢解变得越来越恐怖。
And this is the culminating display of horror. There's clearly a sense that Mary Jane has been the victim of a kind of frenzied series of mutilations. So with that warning, I will give you the details. The whole of the surface of the abdomen and thighs was removed and the abdominal cavity emptied of its viscera. The breasts were cut off, the arms mutilated by several jagged wounds. And the face hacked beyond recognition of the features and the tissues of the neck were severed all round down to the bone.
这是恐怖的巅峰展示。显然，玛丽·简是一系列疯狂肢解行为的受害者。所以，带着这个警告，我将告诉你们细节。腹部和大腿的整个表面被切除，腹腔内的内脏被掏空。乳房被切掉，手臂被几处锯齿状的伤口肢解。脸部被砍得面目全非，颈部组织被完全切断，直达骨头。
The uterus, the kidneys, one of the dismembered breasts had been placed under the head. Then to quote Bond again, the other breast by the right foot, the liver between the feet, the intestines by the right side and the spleen by the left side of the body. Blood, unsurprisingly, had soaked into the bed linen and into the mattress, and there was a still wet pool of blood that had spilled onto the floor. The heart had clearly been cut out and was nowhere to be found. And again, to quote Bond, the wall by the right side of the bed,
子宫、肾脏、一个被肢解的乳房被放在头下。然后引用邦德的话，另一个乳房在右脚旁，肝脏在双脚之间，肠子在右侧，脾脏在身体左侧。不出所料，血已经浸透了床单和床垫，地板上还有一滩尚未干涸的血迹。心脏显然被挖走了，不知去向。再次引用邦德的话，床右侧的墙壁，
and in a line with the neck was marked by blood which had struck it in a number of separate splashes. So Mary Jane Kelly is the first of the Ripper's victims to be murdered not out in the streets or in a yard or something
与颈部平齐的地方有血迹，那是几处独立的喷溅痕迹。所以玛丽·简·凯利是开膛手杰克的第一位不是在街上、院子里或其他地方被谋杀的受害者，
but in a secluded private room and that's what's allowed the Ripper to take his time. Yes, to take his time and to indulge himself, I suppose, by going to the absolute extreme and extreme such that when the guy we mentioned last time
而是在一个隐蔽的私人房间里，这正是让开膛手可以从容行事的原因。是的，从容行事，并且沉溺其中，我想，通过达到极致，这种极致使得当我们上次提到的那个家伙，
Joseph Barnett, a guy who's basically been Mary Jane Kelly's companion who's been living with her and had lived with her until 10 days before the murder. When he was brought to identify her, she's no longer a recognisable human being. It's a butcher shambles. Yeah. He can identify by the hair
约瑟夫·巴尼特（Joseph Barnett），基本上是玛丽·简·凯利的伴侣，一直和她住在一起，直到谋杀案发生前10天。当他被带去辨认她时，她已经不再是一个可辨认的人类了。那是一个屠宰场。是的。他只能通过头发
and by the eyes, but nothing else. Yeah, that's all that is left that enables him to identify her. So we should put not just a face, but a life to Mary Jane Kelly. Who was she? You've said how her murder is kind of different to other ones because it's the only one that takes place in a private room. Yeah. She's also significantly different to previous victims in that she is much
和眼睛来辨认，除此之外别无他法。是的，这就是留下来让他辨认的全部特征。所以我们不仅要给玛丽·简·凯利一张脸，还要给一个人生。她是谁？你说过她的谋杀案与其他案件有何不同，因为它是唯一发生在私人房间里的。是的。她与之前的受害者也有显著不同，因为她年轻得多。
younger. So we've said she's 25. She's also reputedly very pretty. And we have no way of knowing because when you look at the photograph, you know, there's no trace of a human face there really. You know, as we said, he had, the Ripper had spared her eyes and had spared her hair. And these were the two physical attributes for which Mary Jane was particularly noted. So someone described her as having blue eyes and a very fine head of hair, which reached nearly to her waist. Now, what colour was her hair? Some said it was blonde. Other said it was chestnut. One of her nicknames was Black Mary. Another was Ginger. And it may seem odd to be speculating about the colour of her hair. But I do so because the confusion is typical of almost
所以我们说她25岁。据说她也非常漂亮。我们无法得知，因为当你看着照片时，你知道，那里真的没有人类面孔的痕迹。你知道，正如我们所说，他，开膛手留下了她的眼睛和头发。而这两个身体特征正是玛丽·简特别引人注目的地方。所以有人形容她有一双蓝眼睛和一头非常漂亮的头发，长到腰间。那么，她的头发是什么颜色的？有人说是金色的。其他人说是栗色的。她的绰号之一是“黑玛丽”。另一个是“姜黄”。猜测她头发的颜色似乎很奇怪。但我这样做是因为这种混乱几乎是我们所知的关于她生活的一切的典型。好吧，我们实际上什么都不知道，不是吗？我的意思是，我们知道的非常非常少。这就像一个镜厅。所以我们甚至不知道，我的意思是，人们常说她是爱尔兰人，但我们甚至不知道她是否是。她可能是威尔士人，对吧？所以她声称自己来自爱尔兰。
everything that we know about her life. Well, we know nothing effectively, do we? I mean, we know very, very little. It's just a sort of hall of mirrors. So we don't even know, I mean, it's often said that she was Irish, but we don't even know that she was. She might have been Welsh, right? So she claimed to have come from Ireland.
她声称自己来自威尔士。她最常说的故事是她的父母是爱尔兰人，但在她很小的时候就搬到了威尔士。但令人惊讶的是，她既没有爱尔兰口音，也没有威尔士口音。所以有可能她上过发音课，或者她根本就不是爱尔兰人或威尔士人。事实上，我们甚至不能确定玛丽·简·凯利是她的真名，因为这正是那种假装是爱尔兰人的人会想出的名字。完全正确。引用哈莉·鲁宾霍尔德（Hallie Rubinhold）在她的书《五人》（The Five）中所说的，你知道，她对其他受害者的生活给出了非常详细的描述，
She claimed to have come from Wales. The story that she most regularly said was that her parents were Irish but had moved to Wales when she was very young. But it's striking that she had neither an Irish nor a Welsh accent. And so it's possible that perhaps she had elocution lessons or perhaps she was never Irish or Welsh in the first place. And in fact, we can't even be sure that Mary Jane Kelly was her real name because it's exactly the kind of name that someone pretending to be Irish would come up with. Exactly. And to quote Hallie Rubinhold in whose book The Five, you know, she gives very detailed accounts of the lives of.
所有这些都经过专业考证，借鉴了各种书面材料。但她谈到玛丽·简·凯利时说，她关于自己抵达伦敦之前的生活所做的每一项陈述从未得到证实。你知道，人们翻遍了记录。他们从未发现任何东西。所以，我们不知道，例如，她来自什么阶层，她的社会地位是什么，对吧？因为约瑟夫·巴尼特会给她读关于开膛手罪行的故事，这表明她是文盲。但其他认识她的人说，
the other victims, all of them expertly sourced, kind of drawing on all kinds of written material. But she says of Mary Jane Kelly, not a single statement made by her about her life prior to her rival in London has ever been verified. You know, people have crawled over the records. They've never found anything. So we don't know, for example, what class she's from, what her social status is, do we? Because Joseph Barnett would read her stories about the Ripper's crimes which suggest that she's illiterate. But other people who knew her said,
我引用一下，“一位优秀的学者和一位不俗的艺术家。”是的。所以是人们在编造东西吗？还是她自己没有告诉人们关于她生活的真相？例如，她说，不是吗，她的父亲
and I quote, an excellent scholar and an artist of no mean degree. Yeah. So are people making stuff up? Or is she herself not telling people the truth about her life? So, for example, she says, doesn't she, that her father
曾是威尔士钢铁厂的工头。她说她有一个在苏格兰卫队的兄弟。但没有任何证据表明这些事情是真的。她不会是唯一一个这样的人，伊丽莎白·斯泰德（Elizabeth Stride）也编造了关于自己的故事。
had been a Welsh steelworks foreman. She says she's got a brother in the Scots Guards. But there's no evidence that either of those things are true at all. And she wouldn't be the only person, Elizabeth Stride, made up stories about herself.
也是如此。我的意思是，如果你跌落到底层，寻求幻想的庇护并不是一件罕见的事情。是的，但在瑞典有一些佐证记录，使研究人员能够推断出她早年的生活可能是什么样子。我们对玛丽·简没有这些记录。好吧，例如，玛丽·简声称她结过婚。同样，没有任何记录。至于她的职业，那些认识她的人都同意。同样，这是她与之前受害者之间的一个不同点。她被警察称为“普通妓女”，即自认为是妓女的人，其职业生涯一直涉及卖淫。她讲述的关于她在伦敦作为妓女生活的早期故事，
as well. I mean, it's not an uncommon thing to do if you've fallen down to the bottom that you take refuge in fantasies. Yeah, but there are kind of substantiating records in Sweden that enable researchers to work out what her earlier as might have been like. We don't have those with Mary Jane. Well, for instance, Mary Jane claims that she had married. Again, there's no record of this whatsoever. As for her career, so those who knew her were agreed. And again, this is a point of difference between her and the previous victims. She was what the police termed a common prostitute, i.e. someone who self-identified as such, whose career had always involved prostitution. The early stories that she tells of her life as a prostitute in London are
实际上很让人想起艾玛·汉密尔顿（Emma Hamilton）。有一种乡村女孩来到伦敦并过上上流生活的感觉，实际上是通过成为非常富有男人的高级交际花。就像左拉（Zola）笔下的人物娜娜（Nana），当时很多人都很熟悉。是的，或者穿着非常紧身骑马装的“弹珠”（Skittles）。所以玛丽·简讲述了她在骑士桥（Knightsbridge）一家非常非常高档的妓院里如何取得了巨大成功，那是西区最高档的地区之一，她有漂亮的衣服，她坐着马车到处走，她在时尚餐厅吃牡蛎，所有这些事情，用她自己的话说，她过着淑女的生活。也许这的一个标志是玛丽·简，她似乎决定这还不够好。所以
actually quite reminiscent of Emma Hamilton. There's a kind of the quality of the country girl who comes to London and leads the high life, effectively by being a call. artisan for very wealthy men. Like Zola's character, Nana, which a lot of people would have been familiar with at the time. Yes, or Skittles with her very tight writing habit. And so Mary Jane tells stories about how she had made a great success for herself in a very, very upmarket brothel in Knightsbridge, which is one of the kind of the classiest areas of the West End, that she had had beautiful dresses, that she'd ridden around in a carriage, that she'd eaten oysters in fashionable restaurants, all. this kind of thing, that in her own words, she had led the life of a lady. And perhaps a marker of that is that Mary Jane, she seems to have decided it wasn't good enough for her. And so
她开始称自己为玛丽·珍妮特（Marie-Jeanette）。法语的暗示很能说明问题，因为她还讲了一个故事，说她被一个所谓的“绅士”带到了巴黎。但她说她只在那里待了半个月，然后就回到了伦敦。但当她回到伦敦时，她没有回到西区。她没有回到她那马车、漂亮衣服和牡蛎的生活。她去了东区，这很令人费解。那两周发生了什么变化？她讲述的故事充满了情节剧。她强烈暗示她在东区是因为她在躲避那些想抓她的人，但谁呢？她发起了一次失败的尝试，试图解放
she starts referring to herself as Marie-Jeanette. And the hint of the French is telling because she also told a story about how she had been taken to Paris by quote-unquote a gentleman. But she had only stayed there, she said, at fortnight and then returned to London. But when she comes back to London, she doesn't go back to the West End. She doesn't go back to her life of carriages and beautiful dresses and oysters. She goes to the East End and that's puzzling. What had changed in those two weeks. And the stories that she tells are kind of full of melodrama. She strongly implies that she's in the East End because she's hiding from people who are out to get her, but who? She launches an abortive attempt to liberate.
一箱她声称在骑士桥一所房子里的衣服，但并没有什么结果。她还说，一个男人出现在她住的地方附近，声称是她的父亲，但并不是在追捕她。除了她自己报告的内容外，没有任何真正的证据支持这一切。好吧，我把她与左拉的小说《娜娜》进行了比较，关于巴黎的一位交际花。这确实感觉太文学化了，不是吗，有一点。这感觉就像那种你会编造的关于神秘绅士、浪子带你去巴黎的故事。1880年代的报纸上充斥着关于所谓“白奴”的故事，你知道，被绑架并被用作性
a chest full of dresses that she says is in a house in Knightsbridge, but nothing really comes of it. And she also says that a man has appeared near to where she's living, claiming to be her father, but wasn't hunting her down. There's no real evidence for any of this beyond what she herself is reporting. Well, I made the comparison with Zola's novel, Nana, about a courtesan in Paris. And this does all feel too literary, doesn't it, a little bit. It feels like the kind of story that you would make up about kind of, you know, mysterious gentleman kind of rakes taking you to Paris. The newspapers in the 1880s are full of stories about so-called white slavery, you know, girls who've been kidnapped and used as sex
奴隶的女孩。我认为她在编造这些东西，因为这是一个好故事。这让她感觉自己很重要。这让她的顾客觉得她很重要。你知道，这比真相要好，真相是她是一个普通妓女。是的。我的意思是，这让她看起来很迷人。当然，她在出卖自己。如果你能让自己看起来很迷人，那么，你知道，你很可能会为自己创造一个市场。但显然，米勒庭院，她在1888年3月搬进去的，我的意思是，它与迷人恰恰相反。但我认为她搬到那里，更广泛地说是搬到白教堂（Whitechapel），是因为到那时，她已经找到了一个稳定的伴侣，似乎已经放弃了卖淫。她停止了
slaves. I think that she's making this stuff up because it's a good story. It makes her feel important. It makes her customers feel that she is important. You know, it's better than the truth, which is that she's an OBD. Yeah. I mean, it's. makes her seem glamorous. And of course, she is selling herself. And if you can make yourself seem glamorous, then, you know, you're likely to create a market for yourself. But obviously, Miller's court, which she'd moved into by March 1888, I mean, it is the opposite of glamorous. But I think she moves in there and into Whitechapel more generally, because by this point, she's found herself a steady partner and seems to have given up on the prostitution. She's stopped
拉客。这个伴侣，我们已经提到过他。他是约瑟夫·巴尼特。这就是那个将来会通过她的眼睛和头发辨认出她的人。他是比林斯盖特（Billingsgate）鱼市场的搬运工。和玛丽·简一样，他有一双蓝眼睛，而且是爱尔兰血统，如果玛丽·简真的是爱尔兰血统的话。巴尼特非常非常喜欢她，非常疼爱她，显然想把日子过好。他把她当作妻子对待。这就是她放弃拉客的原因。他们基本上像夫妻一样生活。但到了1888年秋天，他们的关系变得有点不稳定。7月，巴尼特失去了鱼市场的工作，他偶尔做些体力活，但没有固定的
the soliciting. And this partner, we've already mentioned him. He's Joseph Barnett. This is the guy who will identify her in due course by her eyes and her hair. And he was a porter at Billingsgate fish market. And like Mary Jane, he had blue eyes and he was of Irish extraction, if Mary Jane really was of Irish extraction. And Barnett was very, very keen on her, very fond of her and clearly wanted to make a go of things. He treated her as his wife. That's a why she gives up soliciting. They're essentially living as a married couple. But by the autumn of 1888, their relationship is getting slightly rocky. In July, Barnett had lost his job in the fish market and he gets kind of occasional work as a labourer, but not a regular
收入。所以需要付房租。于是玛丽·简又回到了街头拉客。我认为这显然给他们的关系增加了压力，因为她以热心肠而闻名。她在街头的同事中非常受欢迎，而且我认为更广泛地说，她非常善良。她总是邀请其他妓女，如果天气冷或潮湿什么的，回来分享房间。巴尼特对此不太高兴，不是吗？他觉得这很烦人。实际上，他最终搬出了米勒庭院。所以，在谋杀案发生前不久，大概10天前，他搬走了？他们大吵了一架，他气冲冲地走了，但他不忍心走得太远。
income. And so there's a need to pay the rent. And so Mary Jane returns to soliciting on the streets. And adding to the strain that I think this obviously places on their relationship is the fact that she is famously warm-hearted. She's terribly popular among her fellow workers on the street. And I think more generally, very kind-hearted. And she's always inviting fellow prostitutes if it's cold or wet or whatever to come back and share the room. Barnett's not terribly happy about this, is he? He finds it very annoying. And actually, he ends up moving out of Miller's So not that long before the, what, about 10 days before the murder, he's moved out? They have a massive row and he kind of stalks off, but he can't bear to go too far.
所以他在离她很近的地方找了一个房间。在接下来的那一周里，他回来了，显然是在试图修补与她的关系。他显然想和她复合。他在11月8日晚上回来见她。他是在傍晚时分这样做的。玛丽·简的一位邻居，在米勒庭院，后来报告说他们看起来关系很好。巴尼特本人在接受警方采访时说：“我告诉她我没有工作，我没有什么可以给她的，我对此感到非常抱歉。”他随后在7点45分左右离开。
So he finds a room very close to her. And over the week that follows, he comes back and he's clearly trying to patch things up with her. He clearly wants to get back with her. And he comes back to her to see her on the evening of the 8th of November. He does this kind of in the early evening. And a neighbour of Mary Jane, so in Miller's Court, reported later that they seemed to be on the best of terms. And Barnett himself, when he was interviewed by the police, he said, I told her that I had no work and that I had nothing to give her, for which I was very sorry. He then left around 745.
对。他很抱歉，为什么？因为她需要钱。好吧，当然，我们知道她需要钱，因为我们知道她拖欠了六周的房租，对吧？所以如果巴尼特没有钱给她，她去哪里弄钱付给房东呢？对麦卡锡的性格有各种各样的解读。所以哈莉在《五人》中对他评价很低，称他为恶霸，并暗示他总是试图勒索钱财。其他人说他其实很喜欢玛丽·简。
Right. And he's sorry, why? Because she needs money. Well, of course, we know she needs money because we know that she's behind on the rent by six weeks, right? So if Barnett doesn't have the money to give her, where is she going to get the money to pay the landlord? There are various kind of interpretations of McCarthy's character. So Hallie in The Five is very down on him, calls him a bully and implies that he's always trying to extort money out of him. Others say that he was quite fond of Mary Jane.
我想，你知道，六周的房租确实很多，因为我们描述的所有其他女性，几乎无一例外，她们因为没有钱支付一晚的房租而被赶出床位。是的。而玛丽·简在她的房间里待了六周。完全正确。但你可以看出为什么他，你知道，也许他失去了耐心。也许他试图施加压力。我认为这显然就是为什么那天晚上，尽管雨下得非常、
And I guess that, you know, six weeks back rent is quite a lot because all the all the other women that we've been describing, almost invariably, they're being turfed out of their bed because they don't have money to pay for a single night. Yeah. Whereas Mary Jane is in her room and is there for six weeks. Exactly. But you can see why he, you know, maybe he's running out of patience. Maybe he's trying to turn the screws. And I think that that is clearly why that evening, despite the fact that the rain is very,
非常大，玛丽·简似乎急于拉客。在约瑟夫·巴尼特走后，她显然离开了房间，走到街上，试图招揽生意。我们有两位证人后来声称那天晚上看到她和男人在一起。第一位是一个人，他被一个从米勒庭院周围顶层往下看的人看到陪她进入房间。所以他被我们提到的那盏煤气灯照亮了。他被描述为留着浓密的胡须，
very torrential, Mary Jane seems to have been desperate to solicit clients. After Joseph Bennett has gone, she clearly leaves her room and goes out into the streets and is trying to attract custom. and we have two witnesses who would subsequently claim to have seen her with men that night. And the first of these is a man who is seen accompanying her into her room by someone who is looking down from one of the top stories around Miller's court. So he is lit by that gas lamp that we mentioned. And he's described as having a thick, carotie moustache,
穿着破旧的深色衣服，穿着深色大衣，戴着黑色毡帽。他在午夜前被看到和玛丽·简一起走进房间。是的，玛丽·简当时据报道喝得很醉，她有心情唱一首爱尔兰民谣。我们知道，歌词我发现非常悲伤，充满了悲情。所以她唱道：“童年的场景浮现在我的眼前，勾起了往昔快乐时光的回忆，当我在童年时在草地上漫步，现在那座老房子里没有人能安慰我了。”所以无论她是谁，她显然已经把家抛在脑后，她没有家人会承认她，或者会承认她，甚至可能不知道她在哪里。所以有一种，我发现有一种令人难以置信的悲情。
he's dressed in shabby dark clothes, he's got a dark overcoat, he's got a black felt hat. and he is seen just before midnight he's going into the room with with mary jane yeah and mary jane at the time was reportedly quite drunk she was in a mood for an irish ballad um and we know it and the lyrics i find incredibly sad kind of so full of pathos so she sang scenes of my childhood arise before my gaze bringing recollections of bygone happy days when down in the meadow in childhood i would roam no one's left to cheer me now within that good old home so whoever she was she'd clearly left her home behind and she had no family that she would acknowledge or who would acknowledge her or maybe even knew where she was so there is a kind i find an incredible pathos about that
那么第二位证人呢？第二位证人是一位名叫乔治·哈钦森（George Hutchinson）的失业劳工。他对玛丽·简有点迷恋，不是吗？是的。所以他以前见过她，会不时给她钱。是的。他当时没有工作。所以当他在凌晨2点左右在街上遇到玛丽·简时，
and what about the second witness so the second witness is an unemployed laborer called george hutchinson um he had a kind of a bit of a crush on mary jane didn't he? Yeah. So he'd seen her before and would periodically give her money. Yeah. He doesn't have a job at the time. So when he runs into Mary Jane walking down Thrill Street around 2 a.m.
她向他要钱，他说：“抱歉，我身无分文，什么都没有。帮不了你。”是的。哈钦森随后说，在玛丽·简与他进行这次交流后，他看到她被第二个男人接近。这是一个脸色苍白的人，据哈钦森说，而且穿着非常考究。他穿着一件阿斯特拉罕皮毛大衣。他们两人讨价还价，达成协议，哈钦森随后看着他们两人消失在多塞特街，走进了通往米勒庭院的黑暗小巷。好吧，他给出了非常详细的描述，不是吗？所以我读一下。“浅色背心，深色长裤，中间向下翻的深色毡帽。系带靴和绑腿，带有白色纽扣，穿着非常厚。厚金链，白色亚麻领，黑色领带，带有马蹄形别针，体面的外表，
And she asks him for money and he says, sorry, I'm skin, haven't got anything. Can't help. Yeah. And Hutchinson then says after this exchange that Mary Jane had had with him, he had watched her be approached by a second man. And this is a person who's pale face, according to Hutchinson. and very well-dressed. He's wearing an Astrakhan coat. And the two of them, Haggle, terms are agreed, and Hutchinson then watches the two of them disappear off Dorset Street down the dark alleyway that leads into Miller's court. Well, he gives a very detailed description, doesn't he? So I'll just read it. Light waistcoat, dark trousers and a dark felt hat turned down in the middle. Button boots and gaiters with white buttons wore a very thick. thick gold chain white linen collar, black tie with horseshoe pin, respectable appearance
走路非常快，犹太人的外表。”是的，他随后会给出对这个男人的另一个更详细的描述。人们可能会怀疑，天很黑，他们站在阴影里，他能看到每一个细节的可能性有多大？我们将在适当的时候讨论这个问题。但为了完成哈钦森证据的细节，他说他在米勒庭院入口处等了不到一个小时，
walked very sharp, Jewish appearance. Yes, and he will then go on to give another even more detailed description of this man. And people may wonder, it's dark, they're standing in shadows, how plausible is it that he would have seen every detail? and we will come to this in due course. But just to finish detailing Hutchinson's evidence, he said that he'd waited by the entrance of Miller's court for just under an hour
玛丽·简和她的客户都没有再出现。如果他值得信任，他们在大约2点钟消失在她的房间里。而他，如果他值得信任的话，是最后一个看到她活着的人，但也许不是最后一个听到玛丽·简声音的人，因为有两个不同的女人，其中一个是名叫伊丽莎白·普拉特（Elizabeth Prater）的女人，
and that neither Mary Jane nor her client reappeared. If he can be trusted, they had disappeared into her room around 2 o'clock. And he, again, if he's to be trusted, is the last witness to see her alive, but not perhaps the last to hear Mary Jane's voice because there are two separate women and one of them is a woman called Elizabeth Prater
她是玛丽·简房间正上方的房客，另一个是名叫莎拉·刘易斯（Sarah Lewis）的洗衣女工，她无家可归，在米勒庭院13号对面、跨过庭院的房间里与一对夫妇避难。这两个女人都报告说在凌晨4点左右听到了谋杀的尖叫声。
who is the lodger in the rooms directly above Mary Jane's room and the other is a laundress called Sarah Lewis who has been made homeless and is taking refuge with a couple on the room opposite 13 mill of court across the courtyard and both these women reported hearing screams of murder at around 4 a.m.
是的。听众可能想知道，好吧，为什么她们不采取行动呢？事实上，警察问的正是这个问题。普拉特夫人说，她告诉警察：“我没有太注意这些叫声，因为我经常听到这样的叫声。”对。值得补充的是，尸检，做尸检的医生，外科医生，他们认为最可能的死亡时间是在凌晨4点左右。虽然如果这是真的，而且乔治·哈钦森的故事是真的，那么这意味着有两个小时的间隔，
Yeah. And listeners may be wondering, well, why didn't they do something about it? And in fact, the police asked exactly this question. And Mrs. Prater said, she told the police, I did not take much notice of the cries as I frequently hear such cries. Right. And it is worth adding that the autopsy, the doctors who did that, the surgeons, they suggested that the likeliest time of death was around 4 a.m. Although if that's true and George Hutchison's story is true, then that means there's been a two-hour interval
在凶手进入房间和谋杀实际发生之间，这很奇怪，因为在之前的每一个案件中，开膛手都杀得非常快且高效。现在我可以理解开膛手可能想和尸体单独待在一起几个小时来进行肢解，
between the killer going into the room and then the murder actually happening which would be odd given that in every previous case the Ripper has killed very quickly and efficiently now I can understand the Ripper might want to be alone with the body to do his mutilations for hours
在这两个小时里他们一直在做什么，这在这次杀戮之前从未发生过，对吧？所以那两个在玛丽·简死亡当晚与她在一起的嫌疑人，都被认为是开膛手的有力候选人。但我认为实际上他们两人都不一定是。
what have they been doing for two hours which is never done before before this killing right so those two suspects who are seen with Mary Jane on the evening of her death both of them have been identified as very strong candidates to have been the Ripper. But I think actually neither of them necessarily are.
我认为那个留着胡须的家伙，我的意思是，显然，你知道，他在午夜刚过就进去了。是的。玛丽·简急需大量的客户。完全有可能她确实出去了，也许带回了这个穿阿斯特拉罕大衣的家伙。在那之后，完全有可能她又出去了，带回了可能是开膛手的人。是的。所以这不是决定性的。但无论最终在凌晨4点左右和玛丽·简待在那个房间里的人是谁，
I think the guy with the Karateen Mastash, I mean, clearly, you know, he's going in at just after midnight. Yeah. Mary Jane is desperate for large numbers of clients. It's perfectly possible that she did go out and maybe get this guy in the Astrakhan coat. And it's perfectly possible after that that she went out and got someone else who might be the Ripper. Yeah. So it's not definitive. But whoever it was that ended up in that room with Mary Jane at around 4 o'clock in the morning,
我们知道结果，因为我们已经描述了它所有的恐怖细节。当然，检查的外科医生需要时间来理解这种恐怖。直到下午4点，你不能真正称之为尸体，玛丽·简·凯利被肢解的遗骸才从她的房间里移走。到那时，一辆盖着防水布的马车已经到达，正在通往多塞特街的黑暗通道外等待。现在，正如开膛手杰克谋杀案变得司空见惯的那样，大量的人群聚集在犯罪现场外。
we know the upshot because we have described it in all its hideous detail. And of course it takes time for the examining surgeons to make sense of the horror. And it's not until 4 o'clock in the afternoon that you can't really call it a body. the kind of the remains, the mangled remains of Mary Jane Kelly is removed from her room. And by this point, a cart with a tarpauling cover has arrived and is waiting outside the dark passageway that leads out into Dorset Street. And by now, as is becoming commonplace with a Jack the Ripper murder, huge numbers of people are gathering outside the scene of the crime. and they are swelled by the fact that it's the Lord Mayor's show and as the news of the murder has swept the crowds in the city of London
他们的人数因为是市长巡游日而增加，随着谋杀的消息席卷伦敦城的人群，
so huge numbers have left the route of the procession and started flocking into Whitechapel in a kind of state of mass hysteria and when Mary Jane's body is brought out by the police and laid onto the cart the police who are keeping order in Dorset Street have to form a cordon to hold the crowds back and a journalist from the Times the next morning reported on this.
大量的人离开了游行路线，开始涌入白教堂，处于一种集体歇斯底里的状态。当玛丽·简的尸体被警察抬出来放在马车上时，在多塞特街维持秩序的警察不得不组成警戒线来阻挡人群。第二天早上，《泰晤士报》的一位记者对此进行了报道。
The crowd was of the humblest class, but the demeanour of the poor people was all that could be desired. Ragged caps were doffed and slatternly-looking women shed tears as the shell covered with a ragged looking cloth was placed in the van. And then the inquests are held, and ten days later, when Mary Kelly's funeral is held at Shoreditch Church, no family member could be found to attend the funeral. So she remains a mystery.
“人群属于最卑微的阶层，但穷人们的表现却无可挑剔。破烂的帽子被摘下，衣衫褴褛的妇女们在盖着破布的壳被放入货车时流下了眼泪。”然后举行了调查，十天后，当玛丽·凯利的葬礼在肖尔迪奇教堂（Shoreditch Church）举行时，找不到任何家庭成员来参加葬礼。所以她仍然是一个谜。
Yeah. Instead, riding in the two morning carriages that are accompanying the hearse to the Catholic Cemetery in Leightonston are six women who had known her. And these include Elizabeth Prater and Sarah Lewis, the two women who had heard the cry of murder at 4 a.m. A mourner representing John McCarthy, her landlord, and Joseph Barnett. And it was Barnett who had insisted that she should be buried as a Catholic. So I think clearly he believed that she was Irish. Because obviously, you know, if she'd been Welsh, he would have directed her to a Methodist chapel or something. Yeah, of course.
是的。相反，坐在陪同灵车前往莱顿斯通（Leytonstone）天主教公墓的两辆哀悼马车里的，是六位认识她的女性。其中包括伊丽莎白·普拉特和莎拉·刘易斯，那两个在凌晨4点听到谋杀尖叫声的女人。一位代表她的房东约翰·麦卡锡的哀悼者，以及约瑟夫·巴尼特。正是巴尼特坚持认为她应该以天主教徒的身份下葬。所以我认为显然他相信她是爱尔兰人。因为显然，你知道，如果她是威尔士人，他会把她送到卫理公会教堂什么的。是的，当然。
And it's also Barnett who insists that her name on both the kind of the brass coffin plate and on her gravestone should read Marie Jeanette Kelly. So the glamorous French sophisticated name that she would have always wanted, right? Yes. She was clearly a woman who enjoyed attention. And she certainly gets attention at her funeral because huge crowds gather to watch the procession and women sob and again men are doffing their caps as the open hearse passes by. And as you suggest Dominic, in death, she's become what I think she had always dreamed of being, which is essentially the heroine of. melodrama, no matter how dark and terrible the melodrama has actually turned out to be. And bystanders weep at the thought of the fate that has befallen her, and they pray to God to forgive her, and they are, I think, hailing her, enshrining her as a symbol of their collective defiance of the fiend who had brought her to her terrible doom. Well, you call him a fiend, but of course, Jack the Ripper was all too human.
而且正是巴尼特坚持要求她在黄铜棺材牌和墓碑上的名字都应写为玛丽·珍妮特·凯利。所以，这正是她一直想要的那个迷人、法国化、精致的名字，对吧？是的。她显然是一个喜欢受人关注的女人。她在葬礼上确实受到了关注，因为大批人群聚集观看送葬队伍，女人们啜泣，男人们在灵车经过时再次脱帽致敬。正如你所暗示的，多米尼克，在死后，她成为了她一直梦想成为的人，本质上就是一部情节剧的女主角，无论这部情节剧最终变得多么黑暗和可怕。旁观者为她所遭遇的命运而落泪，他们祈求上帝宽恕她，我认为，他们是在赞美她，将她供奉为他们共同反抗那个将她带入可怕厄运的恶魔的象征。好吧，你称他为恶魔，但当然，开膛手杰克也是一个彻头彻尾的人。
And after the break, we will come back to look at what people make of the Ripper now that he has struck again. And the impact that it has on popular culture, because of course, this is the age of Sherlock Holmes of Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde, and people are very much interpreting the Ripper's crimes against that backdrop. So we'll be digging into all this after the break. This episode is brought to you by NordVPN. Christmas should be a time for relaxing and letting loose. But history teaches us that letting our guards down could allow bad actors to strike. Fortunately, in 2025, we don't need a turret or a moat to stay safe.
休息之后，我们将回来看看人们在开膛手再次作案后对他有何看法。以及这对流行文化产生的影响，因为当然，这是夏洛克·福尔摩斯和杰基尔博士与海德先生的时代，人们非常倾向于在这一背景下解读开膛手的罪行。所以我们将在休息后深入探讨这一切。本集由NordVPN赞助播出。圣诞节本应是放松和释放自我的时光。但历史告诉我们，放松警惕可能会让不法分子有机可乘。幸运的是，在2025年，我们不需要炮塔或护城河来保持安全。
We just need NordVPN. At the click of a button, NordVPN's powerful software encrypts your data and Threat Protection Pro blocks malicious links and scans downloads for viruses. It covers up to 10 devices or can be attached to your router to protect your whole home. It also helps with your Christmas shopping. Online retailers can sneakily change prices based on your location. Fortunately, using NordVPN means you can buy presents with the peace of mind that you're getting the best price. To get the best discount of your NordVPN plan, go to
我们只需要NordVPN。只需点击一下按钮，NordVPN强大的软件就能加密您的数据，Threat Protection Pro功能可以拦截恶意链接并扫描下载文件中的病毒。它最多可覆盖10台设备，或者可以连接到您的路由器以保护整个家庭。它还能帮助您进行圣诞购物。在线零售商可能会根据您的位置偷偷更改价格。幸运的是，使用NordVPN意味着您可以安心购买礼物，确保获得最优惠的价格。要获得NordVPN计划的最大折扣，请前往
NordVPN.com forward slash rest is history. Our link will also give you four extra months on the two-year plan. There's no risk with Nord's 30-day money-back guarantee. The link is in the podcast episode description box. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes. And Uber Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered. It's showing up no matter what. Like for your long distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. Throughout time, celebration has meant giving, so the Romans
NordVPN.com/restishistory。我们的链接还将为您在两年计划的基础上额外提供四个月的服务。Nord的30天退款保证让您毫无风险。链接就在播客剧集描述框中。本集由Uber赞助播出。现在，你知道那种在最需要的时候有人为你挺身而出的感觉吗？我们有时都需要那样。而Uber，Uber不仅仅是一次乘车或一份外卖。无论发生什么，它都代表着挺身而出。就像为了你的远方朋友，在他们生病时送去汤，在他们情绪低落时送去鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论是什么，你都会挺身而出。有志者事竟成，我们正在路上。Uber，我们在路上。立即下载应用程序。纵观历史，庆祝意味着给予，所以罗马人
that Saturnalia handed out all kinds of gifts. The three magi handed out gold, frankincense and myrrh, and the Victorians absolutely loved, wrapping things up in paper and then tying it up in string. It's on those are lovely gestures, but I wonder if they're a little bit too extravagant for the typical Christmas morning. So this year, here's my suggestion to our listeners and our viewers,
在农神节期间会分发各种礼物。三位智者分发了黄金、乳香和没药，而维多利亚时代的人们绝对喜欢用纸把东西包起来，然后用绳子系好。这些都是可爱的姿态，但我怀疑对于典型的圣诞早晨来说，它们是否有点太奢侈了。所以今年，这是我对我们的听众和观众的建议，
why not give something a little bit more enlightened? Why not give the gift of the rest is history, club membership. It's the discerning choice for anybody who prefers a Hannibal to a hamper. It's ad-free listening. You get a weekly bonus episode. You get early access to live shows and you get exclusive deep dive series. Also, on top of that, this year's special gift edition of Restis History Club membership comes with a sensational exclusive t-shirt. It will make you the envy of all your neighbors and all the cool people in your neighborhood, if such people exist, will admire you and want to spend more time with you. So just head to the rest is history.com and click on
为什么不送一份更有启发性的礼物呢？为什么不送一份《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）俱乐部会员资格作为礼物呢？对于任何喜欢汉尼拔胜过喜欢礼品篮的人来说，这是一个有眼光的选择。这是无广告收听。您将获得每周的额外剧集。您将获得现场演出的优先入场权，并获得独家深度系列节目。此外，今年《历史的余味》俱乐部会员资格的特别礼品版还附带一件轰动性的独家T恤。它会让你成为所有邻居羡慕的对象，你社区里所有酷的人（如果这样的人存在的话）都会钦佩你，并想花更多时间和你在一起。所以只需前往therestishistory.com并点击
gifts. That is therestishistory.com and please click on gifts. Welcome back everybody to The Rest is History. Now two months before the murder of Mary Jane Kelly on the 8th of September, the editor of the power, Mal Gazette, W.T. Stead, William Thomas Stead, he had written an absolutely ferocious attack on the police. And the headline was, another murder and more to follow. Instead said, the triumphant success with which the Metropolitan Police have suppressed all political meetings in Trafalgar Square contrasts strangely with their absolute failure to prevent the most brutal kind of murder in Whitechapel. And this is a question that people
礼品（gifts）。网址是therestishistory.com，请点击礼品。欢迎大家回到《历史的余味》。现在，在9月8日玛丽·简·凯利被谋杀前两个月，《帕尔马公报》（Pall Mall Gazette）的编辑W.T.斯特德（威廉·托马斯·斯特德）对警方发动了一次极其猛烈的抨击。头条新闻是《又一起谋杀案，更多案件即将发生》。斯特德说，伦敦警察厅在特拉法加广场镇压所有政治集会所取得的“辉煌成功”，与他们在防止白教堂区发生最残忍的谋杀案方面的彻底失败形成了鲜明对比。这是一个人们
are asking more and more, isn't it? Why have the police who have been so effective at doing the government's bidding at clearing homeless people out of Trafalgar Square on Bloody Sunday in 1887 and beating up demonstrators and whatnot? They're so good at this, but they cannot solve the murders of Polly Nichols and Annie Chapman and of course the subsequent Ripper victims. And we're focusing on stead, aren't we, in the Palmao Gazette? Because this is a man whose career is at its absolute zenith at the time of the Ripper Murders and he has established in many ways the context in which the Ripper Murders are understood. Yeah, so he's been kind of appearing throughout our series so far
越来越频繁地提出的问题，不是吗？为什么那些在1887年“血腥星期日”执行政府命令、清理特拉法加广场上的无家可归者、殴打示威者等方面如此有效的警察，却无法解决波莉·尼科尔斯、安妮·查普曼以及随后的开膛手受害者的谋杀案？我们正在关注《帕尔马公报》的斯特德，对吧？因为这是一个在开膛手谋杀案发生时，其职业生涯正处于绝对巅峰的人，他在许多方面确立了人们理解开膛手谋杀案的背景。是的，所以他似乎一直出现在我们目前的系列节目中，
but I think it's good to kind of dive and have a closer look at him because he has an absolute genius for campaigning journalism. He's the effective inventor of Britain's tabloid press and he is, I think, in a sense, the most interesting contemporary commentator on the series of murders that are taking place. And he's been the editor of the Palmaal Gazette since 1883. And over the course of his term in the editor's chair, he has repeatedly impacted on government policy that in turn has had a knock-on effect on the material circumstances of the people living in Whitechapel. So his first campaign, which he launched in 1883, it drew on a congregationalist pamphlet titled The Bitter Cry of Outcast London.
但我认为深入了解他一下是很好的，因为他在竞选式新闻报道方面拥有绝对的天才。他实际上是英国小报新闻业的发明者，我认为，在某种程度上，他是对正在发生的一系列谋杀案最有趣的当代评论员。自1883年以来，他一直担任《帕尔马公报》的编辑。在他担任编辑期间，他多次影响了政府政策，而这些政策反过来又对居住在白教堂区的人们的物质状况产生了连锁反应。所以他的第一次竞选活动始于1883年，它借鉴了一本名为《被遗弃的伦敦的痛苦呼声》的公理会小册子。
He pushed this very, very hard to highlight the squalor in indignity and horror of London slums. And it played a massive role in encouraging the government to embark on the program of slum clearance that by 1888 was kind of lapping at the borders of Spittle Fields. and ironically had served to make lots of people homeless, to displace people from their homes, and had added to the overcrowding in Whitechapel. So that's one way in which Stead has impacted on events in Flarendine Street and Thrall Street and Dorset Street and so on. Then in 1885, he'd launched his most famous campaign, which we've already briefly mentioned. And this was a series of four articles headlined the maiden tribute of modern Babylon.
他非常努力地推动这一点，以突出伦敦贫民窟的肮脏、屈辱和恐怖。它在鼓励政府着手进行贫民窟清理计划方面发挥了巨大作用，到1888年，该计划已经蔓延到斯皮塔佛德区的边缘。具有讽刺意味的是，它导致许多人无家可归，流离失所，并加剧了白教堂区的过度拥挤。所以这是斯特德影响弗伦丁街、特拉尔街和多塞特街等地事件的一种方式。然后在1885年，他发起了他最著名的竞选活动，我们已经简要提到过。这是一系列以《现代巴比伦的少女贡品》为标题的四篇文章，
and it detailed how members of the British elite were preying on young working class girls, how these girls were, and I quote, snared, trapped and outraged. And Stead was kind of ramped up the horror of this in brilliantly melodramatic terms. So here is. Do the girls cry out? Of course they do. But what avails screaming in a quiet bedroom? and his most spectacular, his most notorious stunt
它详细描述了英国精英阶层的成员是如何捕食年轻的工人阶级女孩的，这些女孩是如何被——我引用——“诱捕、困住和蹂躏”的。斯特德以极其精彩的情节剧风格渲染了这种恐怖。所以这里是。女孩们会尖叫吗？当然会。但在安静的卧室里尖叫有什么用呢？他最引人注目、最臭名昭著的噱头
was literally to buy a 13-year-old girl for five pounds from her mother. Eliza Armstrong, her name was. Yeah, a massive scandal that he did this. And he took her, didn't he, to, what did he take her to? I can't remember where he took her. But he didn't do anything to her, but the whole point of it was to demonstrate that it could be done.
实际上是从一个母亲那里以五英镑的价格买下了一个13岁的女孩。她的名字叫伊丽莎·阿姆斯特朗。是的，他这样做引起了巨大的丑闻。他带她去了，不是吗？他带她去了哪里？我不记得他带她去了哪里。但他并没有对她做什么，但整个事情的重点是证明这是可以做到的。
And he actually ends up being prosecuted for it, which just kind of compounds the, publicity effect of the whole campaign. And the impact of this is both immense and immediate. And it leads directly in the same year of 1885 to the Criminal Law Amendment Act, which is a very momentous piece of legislation. So it rages the age of consent for girls from 13 to 16. But it is also the act which led to the closure of brothels, which we mentioned in the first episode, which had seen prostitutes evicted from their rooms and sent again out into Whitechapel. So this again is part of what is making Whitechapel even more of a hotbed of overcrowding
他最终因此被起诉，这反而加剧了整个竞选活动的宣传效果。其影响既巨大又直接。它直接导致了1885年《刑事法律修正案》的通过，这是一项非常重大的立法。它将女孩的同意年龄从13岁提高到了16岁。但这也是导致妓院关闭的法案，我们在第一集中提到过，这导致妓女被赶出房间，再次被送回白教堂区。所以这再次成为使白教堂区变得比以前更加拥挤
and vice than it had been before. And just to add one other impact that it has, it makes gross indecency between male adults illegal. Yeah, that's the so-called Labusherit Amendment under which Oscar Wilde was convicted later on. Yeah. and which I think will stay on the statute book until the 1960s. Yeah, until 1967. So it has a huge effect on the kind of the law governing sexual crimes in Britain.
和充满罪恶的温床的原因之一。还要补充一点它产生的影响，它使成年男性之间的严重猥亵行为成为非法。是的，这就是所谓的拉布谢尔修正案，奥斯卡·王尔德后来就是根据该修正案被定罪的。是的。我认为它会一直保留在法典中直到20世纪60年代。是的，直到1967年。所以它对英国管辖性犯罪的法律产生了巨大的影响。
But it also has a massive influence on the cultural climate. And it whips up a sense that aristocratic predators are everywhere, stalking working class girls. And there's a slight, I think in terms of the obsession with it, there's perhaps a slight hint of kind of Jeffrey Epstein. The kind of fascination of that case for people is the fact that his clients are all seen as being members of the elite princes and presidents and and so on. And it's massively amplified by reports in the Palmaal Gazette in the years that follow of sex crimes that focus very, very precisely on, you know, the iniquity of aristocrats and baronets and people like that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. These are crimes carried out.
但它也对文化氛围产生了巨大的影响。它煽动了一种感觉，即贵族掠夺者无处不在，跟踪工人阶级的女孩。我认为在对它的痴迷方面，有一点点类似于杰弗里·爱泼斯坦的影子。那个案件之所以让人们着迷，是因为他的客户都被视为精英阶层的成员，王子、总统等等。在随后的几年里，《帕尔马公报》关于性犯罪的报道极大地放大了这一点，这些报道非常精确地聚焦于贵族、从男爵和这类人的罪恶。是的，是的，是的。这些是
by people in top hats with kind of expensive suitcases who are whisking girls off to Paris and then outraging them. I mean, that's the formula, isn't it? So these crimes, Stead is not interested in the Palmao Gazette is not interested in crimes of abuse or exploitation that are committed by people lower down the social spectrum, particularly. Right. So again, I mean, people are much more interested in what Prince Andrew did than say groomers and predators from, you know, in Britain who were not princes. Right. And Stead is not interested, basically, in the grooming of working class girls by working
戴着高礼帽、带着昂贵手提箱的人所犯下的罪行，他们把女孩带到巴黎，然后蹂躏她们。我的意思是，这就是公式，对吧？所以这些罪行，斯特德并不感兴趣，《帕尔马公报》对社会阶层较低的人所犯下的虐待或剥削罪行并不特别感兴趣。对吧。所以，人们对安德鲁王子做了什么比对英国那些不是王子的诱拐者和掠夺者更感兴趣。对吧。而且斯特德基本上对工人阶级男性诱拐工人阶级女孩不感兴趣，
class men. And I think that had Stead come across the story of the upper class rate taking Mary Jane Kelly to Paris, he would have been all over it. And it may be that, you know, there was an aristocrat who had groomed and trafficked her. I mean, we don't know. Stead is reporting things that did actually happen. But as you suggested, I think it's equally possible that Mary Jane, who's clearly very interested in newspaper reports and melodrama and stories of crime and so on, that she might
我认为，如果斯特德偶然发现了上层阶级强奸犯带玛丽·简·凯利去巴黎的故事，他一定会大肆报道。可能确实有一位贵族诱拐并贩卖了她。我的意思是，我们不知道。斯特德报道的事情确实发生了。但正如你所暗示的，我认为玛丽·简同样有可能——她显然对报纸报道、情节剧和犯罪故事非常感兴趣——她可能
have picked it up and kind of cast herself as the heroine of such a drama. And she's clearly not the only person picking this up, right? Because I would argue that so much of the mystique of Jack, the so-called mystique, I mean, it's a terrible thing to say about somebody who committed such horrendous crimes, that so much of the mystique and the, um, the ill-gotten glamour of Jack the Ripper comes from this idea that he's a bloke in a top hat in a character. rattling down the streets of Whitechapel, through the fog, seducing these young women, and then, you know, venting his awful kind of passions on them. We're basically in W.T. Stead's mental universe, right?
已经接受了这些，并把自己塑造成了这样一部戏剧的女主角。而且她显然不是唯一一个接受这一点的人，对吧？因为我会争辩说，杰克所谓的神秘感——我的意思是，对一个犯下如此可怕罪行的人说这种话是很糟糕的——开膛手杰克的很多神秘感和那种“不义之财”带来的魅力，来自于这样一个想法：他是一个戴着高礼帽、穿着考究的家伙，在雾气中穿过白教堂区的街道，诱惑这些年轻女性，然后把他的可怕激情发泄在她们身上。我们基本上是在W.T.斯特德的精神世界里，对吧？
We are. And, you know, we've had a couple of descriptions that exactly match that image. So there's the one with which we opened this episode. And then, of course, the most famous is the description that Hutchinson gave, the very detailed account of the man that he'd seen talking to Mary Jane Kelly. Oh yeah, the Astrakhan coat or whatever it is. Yeah, a couple of hours before her murder. And it's a report that is taken very seriously by students of Jack the Ripper. So as Philip Suggman puts it, Hutchinson has been widely described by students of the case
我们是。而且，你知道，我们已经有几个完全符合那个形象的描述了。所以我们这一集开头就用了一个。然后，当然，最著名的是哈钦森给出的描述，他对自己看到与玛丽·简·凯利交谈的那个人的非常详细的描述。哦，是的，那件阿斯特拉罕皮大衣什么的。是的，在她被谋杀前几个小时。这是一份被开膛手杰克的研究者非常认真对待的报告。正如菲利普·萨格曼所言，哈钦森被该案的研究者广泛描述为
as the witness most likely to have met Jack the Ripper. And this was certainly what Inspector Abiline seems briefly to have hoped. Because in the report that Hutchinson gave of the man that he had seen, there was this phrase can be identified right at the end. And you can imagine Abiline's hopes soaring when he read that. It is evident that Abiline had very quickly lost confidence in Hutchinson. And so people may wonder why. So I think there are two possible theories.
最有可能见过开膛手杰克的人。这当然是阿伯林督察似乎曾短暂希望过的事情。因为在哈钦森给出的关于他所见之人的报告中，最后有这样一句话：“可以被识别”。你可以想象阿伯林在读到这句话时希望大增。很明显，阿伯林很快就对哈钦森失去了信心。所以人们可能会想为什么。所以我认为有两种可能的理论。
So the first is given by Donald Rumbullo in his book, The Complete Jack the Ripper. And Rumbullough wrote, Hutchinson said the suspect lived in the area and thought that he had seen him in Petticoat Lane Market, so very close to the murder site on a Sunday morning. Possibly he did, and I suspect that the man was probably a street trader, somebody Hutchinson knew by sight, if not by name, and giving his description was an act of spiteful resentment or jealousy on his part at the man's sexual friendship with Kelly.
第一种是唐纳德·伦布洛在他的书《完整的开膛手杰克》中给出的。伦布洛写道，哈钦森说嫌疑人住在该地区，并认为他在周日早上在佩蒂科特巷市场见过他，所以离谋杀现场非常近。可能他确实见过，我怀疑那个人可能是一个街头小贩，一个哈钦森即使叫不出名字也面熟的人，而他给出描述是出于对他与凯利性关系的嫉妒或怨恨。
This suspect seems to have been identified, and both he and Hutchinson are quickly dropped from the investigation. So that's one possibility, isn't it, that Hutchinson is just jealous, and he's pinning this on somebody, a rival. But another is that Hutchinson has been reading the same newspapers or absorbing the same sort of pop cultural stereotypes, and that basically his very, very detailed, too detailed, you might say, description of the man who could be the Ripper,
这个嫌疑人似乎已经被确认，他和哈钦森都很快被排除在调查之外。所以这是一种可能性，不是吗？哈钦森只是嫉妒，他把这件事归咎于某个人，一个竞争对手。但另一种可能是，哈钦森一直在阅读同样的报纸或吸收同样的流行文化刻板印象，基本上他对自己所见那个可能是开膛手的人的非常、非常详细（你可能会说太详细了）的描述，
is actually drawn from melodrama, and he's basically just making stuff up. So he is projecting onto the man that he saw talking to Mary Jane, if he saw anyone at all, his sense of what the Ripper should have looked like and just to quote Judith Valkovits who wrote a wonderful book on all this called City of Dreadful Delight which I highly recommend
实际上是取材于情节剧，他基本上只是在编造。所以他把他所见与玛丽·简·凯利交谈的人（如果他真的见过什么人的话）投射到了他认为开膛手应该有的样子上。引用朱迪思·沃尔科维茨的话，她写了一本关于这一切的精彩书籍，名为《可怕的快乐之城》，我强烈推荐，
she says that Hutchinson's description carefully replicated the costume and stance of the classic stage villain sinister black moustache to bejewed and arrogant who manipulated his privilege and wealth to despoil the vulnerable daughters of the people so in other words even before the Ripper's reign of terror has ended, he's already well on his way to becoming
她说哈钦森的描述仔细复制了经典舞台反派的服装和姿态：邪恶的黑色胡须、傲慢且戴着珠宝，利用他的特权和财富来蹂躏人民脆弱的女儿。换句话说，甚至在开膛手的恐怖统治结束之前，他就已经在成为（传奇）的路上了。
something more than just a figure of flesh and blood. He's becoming essentially a kind of a myth. Yeah. And even before the Miller's Court murder, so the murder of Mary Jane Kelly, there are suspicions, aren't there? There are hints in the newspaper coverage that people are already conflating the actual concrete accounts of what's been happening in Whitechapel. with the stuff that they've been reading, not just in Penny Dreadfuls, but also in relatively high literature. So Stead had written an editorial, hadn't he, another murder and more to follow, two months before the Miller's Court murder, in which he had said, this is a massive shock to us. It's a reminder of the potential of revolting barbarity that lies latent in men. And we have deluded ourselves into thinking that civilization has kept the misdehyde of humanity for,
不仅仅是一个血肉之躯的形象。他本质上正在成为一种神话。是的。甚至在米勒法庭谋杀案，也就是玛丽·简·凯利的谋杀案发生之前，就已经有了怀疑，不是吗？报纸报道中已经有了暗示，人们已经将白教堂地区发生的实际具体事件，与他们所读到的内容混为一谈，这些内容不仅来自廉价惊悚小说，也来自相对高雅的文学作品。所以斯特德在米勒法庭谋杀案发生前两个月写了一篇社论，不是吗？题目是《又一起谋杀案，更多谋杀案即将到来》，他在文中说，这对我们来说是一个巨大的冲击。它提醒我们，人类内心潜藏着令人作呕的野蛮潜力。我们曾自欺欺人地认为文明已经掩盖了人性的阴暗面，
assuming visible shape among us, there certainly seems to be a tolerably realistic impersonification of Mr. Hyde at large in Whitechapel. Yes. And this is an allusion to the great literary sensation of the 1880s, which was the strange case of Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde by Robert Louis Stevenson, still an incredibly famous novella. It had been published two years earlier in 1886. And it told the story of a London doctor, Dr. Henry Jekyll, who is outwardly, you know, a model of respectability, but we are told he has a yearning for unnamed pleasures that fill him, and I
假设在我们中间以可见的形式出现，白教堂地区确实似乎出现了一个相当逼真的海德先生化身。是的。这是对19世纪80年代伟大文学轰动作品的影射，那就是罗伯特·路易斯·史蒂文森的《化身博士》，这仍然是一部极其著名的小说。它于两年前的1886年出版。它讲述了一位伦敦医生亨利·杰基尔博士的故事，他表面上是受人尊敬的典范，但我们被告知他渴望那些无法言说的快乐，这些快乐让他，我
quote, with an almost morbid sense of shame. And so he creates a potion that transforms him into the embodiment of everything within his character that is evil and hidden away, repressed. And this character takes the name of Mr. Edward Hyde. And as Mr. Hyde, Jekyll is free to roam London as he pleases indulging all his basest, cruelest instincts. And ultimately he commits murder. And Jekyll finds that Mr. Hyde is starting to take him over, that he is involuntarily. that he is involuntarily turning into Hyde. So, to quote the novel Ella,
引用，充满了近乎病态的羞耻感。于是他制造了一种药水，将自己变成了他性格中所有邪恶、隐藏和压抑的化身。这个角色取名为爱德华·海德先生。作为海德先生，杰基尔可以自由地在伦敦漫游，沉溺于他所有最卑劣、最残忍的本能。最终，他犯下了谋杀罪。杰基尔发现海德先生开始控制他，他正在不由自主地。他正在不由自主地变成海德。所以，引用这部小说，
the powers of Hyde seem to have grown with the sickliness of Jekyll, and ultimately Jekyll is so appalled by what he's become that he kills himself. And when his friends burst into his laboratory, they find in the clothes of Jekyll the shrunken, deformed, hideous form of Hyde. It's a massive bestseller, and it's so successful that they decide to make a stage version of it. And this appears on the West End stage in the summer of 1888, so exactly around the time that Jack the Ripper is starting his reign of terror. The actor playing, Mr. Hyde, is the kind of the theatre manager, a very famous actor called
海德的力量似乎随着杰基尔的虚弱而增长，最终杰基尔对自己所变成的样子感到震惊，以至于他自杀了。当他的朋友们冲进他的实验室时，他们在杰基尔的衣服里发现了海德那萎缩、畸形、丑陋的身躯。这是一本巨大的畅销书，它非常成功，以至于他们决定制作一个舞台版本。这在1888年夏天出现在西区舞台上，正好是开膛手杰克开始其恐怖统治的时候。扮演海德先生的演员是剧院经理，一位非常有名的演员，名叫
Richard Mansfield, and he's so convincing in the part of Mr. Hyde that numerous people who attend the play accuse him in letters to the police of actually being the Ripper. And ultimately, the staging of the play comes to seem so offensive to the victims and to the terror that is sweeping the capital, that it gets closed down. And the last performance is held to raise money for night refuges for homeless women. Wow. So, I mean, it's kind of an amazing example of the way in which the great fictional archetypes of the late Victorian period are directly intersecting with the horror and the drama of the Jack the Ripper murders. So you can see why with the sort of Jekyll and Hyde enthusiasm of the day that lots of people might
理查德·曼斯菲尔德，他在海德先生这个角色上表现得如此令人信服，以至于许多观看该剧的人在写给警方的信中指控他实际上就是开膛手。最终，该剧的演出对受害者以及席卷首都的恐怖气氛显得如此冒犯，以至于它被停演了。最后一场演出是为了筹集资金，为无家可归的妇女提供夜间避难所。哇。所以，我的意思是，这是一个惊人的例子，说明了维多利亚时代晚期的伟大虚构原型是如何直接与开膛手杰克谋杀案的恐怖和戏剧性交织在一起的。所以你可以明白为什么在当时那种对杰基尔和海德的热情下，很多人可能会
think. Yeah, they might jump to the conclusion, the Whitechapel murders. It's not just that they're exposing the horror at the heart of the imperial capital, a capital of world finance and trade or whatever, but they're exposing the dark passions and sadistic urges that lie within the most respectable people in Britain. And I think there's a political context to this, which is, I mentioned a couple of times that Britain in the 1870s and 1880s is quite a troubled place. The economy barely grows at all after 1873, and there's a sense of impending kind of class conflict. So we've already described the Bloody Sunday thing. You get the first socialist MP in 1888, the year of the Jack the Ripper crimes ago, Robert Cunningham Graham. And actually in January 1889, a radical
认为。是的，他们可能会得出结论，白教堂谋杀案。这不仅仅是揭露了帝国首都——一个世界金融和贸易中心——核心的恐怖，而是揭露了英国最受尊敬的人内心深处的黑暗激情和施虐冲动。我认为这有一个政治背景，我提到过几次，19世纪70年代和80年代的英国是一个相当动荡的地方。1873年后经济几乎没有增长，有一种即将发生阶级冲突的感觉。所以我们已经描述了血腥星期天的事情。1888年，也就是开膛手杰克犯罪的那一年，出现了第一位社会主义议员，罗伯特·坎宁安·格雷厄姆。实际上在1889年1月，一个激进的
coalition wins control of London County Council. So a sense of the widening gap between rich and poor, a sense of polarisation, and against that background, obviously, a lot of people are going to say, well, of course the murderer is from the upper class elite. This is what they do. And, I mean, it's really striking that towards the end of 1888, the assumption that the Ripper is a Toff is becoming so universal that, for instance, to quote Welkowitz, a gentleman making his way along High Hoburn in the city was pounced upon by a man of the labouring class yelling Jack the Ripper. Yeah. People are starting to take it for granted. And if it's not a Toff, then people are starting to think.
联盟赢得了伦敦郡议会的控制权。因此，贫富差距扩大、两极分化的感觉，在这种背景下，显然很多人会说，好吧，凶手当然来自上层精英阶层。这就是他们会做的事。而且，非常引人注目的是，到1888年底，认为开膛手是上流人士的假设变得如此普遍，以至于，引用韦尔科维茨的话，一位在城市高霍本路上行走的绅士被一个劳动阶级的人扑倒，大喊开膛手杰克。是的。人们开始认为这是理所当然的。如果不是上流人士，那么人们开始认为，
it must be a doctor. And if the iconic image of the Ripper, you know, has him dressed in opera cloak and top hat, then it also invariably shows him carrying a black bag, which comes to be seen as being a medical bag. And there are all kinds of reasons why people would be buying into this, which I think listeners to this series will already have picked up on. So there's the fact that the London Hospital is very close to the scenes of the murders. So there are lots of surgeons equipped with knives working there. There's the fact that you have the mutilations and the organ thefts that many of the people conducting the inquests are saying displays a kind of detailed anatomical knowledge.
那一定是个医生。如果开膛手标志性的形象让他穿着歌剧斗篷和高礼帽，那么它也总是显示他带着一个黑色的包，这被视为医疗包。人们会相信这一点有各种各样的原因，我想这个系列的听众已经注意到了。所以，伦敦医院离谋杀现场非常近。所以那里有很多配备手术刀的外科医生在工作。还有就是肢解和器官盗窃，许多进行调查的人说这显示了一种详细的解剖学知识。
At Annie Chapman's inquest, Dr. Phillips had proposed that the removal of her uterus that it's not about a mania or anything like that, that it's about someone wanting to sell the organ. necessary to assume lunacy, he said. There was a market for that missing organ. Yeah. And so you start to get all kinds of theories advancing medical men as the likeliest suspect. So in October, there's a very distinguished journalist on the Daily News, Archibald Forbes,
在安妮·查普曼的调查中，菲利普斯医生曾提出，切除她的子宫并不是因为狂躁症之类的原因，而是因为有人想卖掉这个器官。他说，没有必要假设是精神错乱。那个缺失的器官有市场。是的。于是你开始得到各种各样的理论，推测医务人员是最可能的嫌疑人。所以到了十月，《每日新闻》上有一位非常杰出的记者，阿奇博尔德·福布斯，
who proposed that the murderer was a medical student who'd caught syphilis and was out to revenge himself on prostitutes, and that becomes a very, very popular theory. And there are others who suggest that the Ripper is a vivisectionist. So there's lots of, you know, fear and anxiety about people operating on bodies and that he has been driven mad by his researches into, and I quote, the mysteries of the female sex. And so theories like these are obviously filling the vacuum left by the failure of the police to capture the Whitechapel murderer. And I guess you could also say more precisely their failure to utilize the most up-to-date tools of detection. because, again, we've been talking about this, that, you know, there are people saying you should be using, for instance, fingerprinting, which is just coming in at this time. And the police won't, you know, they won't make that part of formal investigative procedure until the early 20th century.
他提出凶手是一名患有梅毒的医学生，他要向妓女报复，这成了一个非常非常流行的理论。还有其他人认为开膛手是一个活体解剖者。所以，有很多关于人们在尸体上进行手术的恐惧和焦虑，他因为对，我引用，女性性别的奥秘的研究而变得疯狂。所以像这样的理论显然填补了警方未能抓住白教堂凶手的真空。我想你也可以更准确地说，他们未能利用最先进的侦查工具。因为，我们一直在谈论这个，你知道，有人说你应该使用，例如，指纹识别，这在当时刚刚开始出现。而警方不会，你知道，他们直到20世纪初才将其作为正式调查程序的一部分。
And then there are others like bloodhounds that they completely, you know, they make an absolute hallix of. And I think that we've talked about how Sir Charles Warren, the head of the Met, resigns. And he actually resigns on the 8th of November, which is one day before. the murder of Mary Jane Kelly, that even though this resignation is not directly linked to the Ripper murders, it does seem to critics of Scotland Yard to set the seal on the failure of the police. And I think also it encourages amateur detectives to feel that they can do a much better job. Well, the amateur detectives are clearly reflecting a climate in which people are distrustful of the police anyway for political reasons, but they also see the police as incompetent, don't they?
还有像猎犬这样的东西，他们完全，你知道，他们搞得一团糟。我想我们已经谈到了查尔斯·沃伦爵士，大都会警察局局长，是如何辞职的。他实际上是在11月8日辞职的，也就是玛丽·简·凯利谋杀案发生的前一天，尽管这次辞职与开膛手谋杀案没有直接联系，但对于苏格兰场（伦敦警察厅）的批评者来说，这似乎给警方的失败盖棺定论了。而且我认为这也鼓励了业余侦探，让他们觉得他们可以做得更好。嗯，业余侦探显然反映了一种气候，人们因为政治原因本来就不信任警察，但他们也认为警察无能，不是吗？
and there's a sort of flood of amateur detectives would be have-a-go heroes into Whitechapel. Yeah, so there's a director of the Bank of England who disguised himself as a day labourer and kind of roamed the streets. There are detectives who emulate the policeman who dressed up as a woman and they go around Whitechapel in drag.
而且白教堂地区涌现出了一大批业余侦探和想当英雄的人。是的，有一位英格兰银行的董事把自己伪装成日薪工人，在街上游荡。还有侦探模仿警察，男扮女装，在白教堂地区四处走动。
The most notorious amateur detective who investigates the case is a prominent alienist, so someone who deals with mental health problems called Littleton Forbes Winslow and he ran private asylums and was widely seen as a kind of leading expert on mental health
调查此案最臭名昭著的业余侦探是一位著名的精神病学家，也就是处理心理健康问题的人，名叫利特尔顿·福布斯·温斯洛，他经营着私人精神病院，被广泛视为心理健康方面的权威专家，
and he was convinced that the Ripper was in the technical language of the time a lunatic and in fact Winslow said that he knew who the Ripper was but would never reveal it and it has to be said that Winslow and all the other amateur detectives are treated with complete contempt
他确信开膛手用当时的技术语言来说是一个疯子，事实上温斯洛说他知道开膛手是谁，但永远不会透露，必须说温斯洛和其他所有业余侦探都受到了完全的蔑视，
by the police they clearly see them as clowns. Of course there is one amateur detective who is not seen as a clown and this is a fictional amateur detective, the most famous amateur detective of all time, who had made his debut in 1887 in a story called A Study in Scarlet and that was Sherlock Holmes.
被警察视为小丑。当然，有一位业余侦探没有被视为小丑，这就是一位虚构的业余侦探，有史以来最著名的业余侦探，他在1887年的一篇名为《血字的研究》的故事中首次亮相，那就是夏洛克·福尔摩斯。
And the title of that book derives from the notion of a scarlet thread of murder. So running through the colorless scheme of life. And our duty is to unravel it and isolate it and expose every inch of it. And I think in saying that, Holmes is speaking for the times because he is articulating a sense that crime has become susceptible to solutions that were simply undreamed of by earlier ages. And it's really telling that part of the glamour of Sherlock Holmes, the reason that contemporary readers take him seriously as the genius that Conan Doyle is presenting him as is because he is an enthusiast for scientific methods that are ahead of police procedure. So fingerprints,
那本书的书名源于谋杀的红色线索这一概念。贯穿于无色的生活方案中。我们的职责是解开它，隔离它，并揭露它的每一寸。我认为在这样说的时候，福尔摩斯是在为那个时代代言，因为他表达了一种感觉，即犯罪已经变得可以通过前人无法想象的解决方案来解决。非常能说明问题的是，夏洛克·福尔摩斯魅力的一部分，当代读者之所以认真对待他，认为他是柯南·道尔所呈现的天才，是因为他是科学方法的狂热爱好者，这些方法领先于警察程序。所以指纹，
he has an ambivalent relationship to that, but he's interested in it. He analyzes bloodstains. He famously writes a monograph on the 150 types of tobacco ash. You know, he's, he's interested interested in ballistics. And I think that it's an absolutely enduring fantasy of fiction and films that Sherlock Holmes would have solved the Jack the Ripper case. If only he'd been unleashed on it. I think we've got about five different books in this house in which Sherlock Holmes battles Jack the Ripper. Or that Sherlock Holmes perhaps is more closely associated with the Ripper's crimes, as Michael Dibden suggests in The Last Sherlock Holmes Mystery or whatever it's called. It's a brilliant book and there is a massive twist which Tom has begged me not to
他对指纹的态度很矛盾，但他对此很感兴趣。他分析血迹。他写了一篇关于150种烟草灰烬的专著，这很有名。你知道，他对弹道学很感兴趣。我认为，夏洛克·福尔摩斯如果被释放去调查，就能破获开膛手杰克案，这是小说和电影中一个永恒的幻想。我想我们家里大约有五本不同的书，书中夏洛克·福尔摩斯与开膛手杰克进行了较量。或者说，正如迈克尔·迪布丁在《最后的夏洛克·福尔摩斯之谜》或类似书名中所暗示的那样，夏洛克·福尔摩斯可能与开膛手的罪行联系得更紧密。这是一本精彩的书，有一个巨大的转折，汤姆求我不要
give away but is pretty obvious by the way in which I'm describing it. Well, as Holmes would put it, when you have eliminated all which is impossible, then whatever remains, however improbable must be the truth. And that is his, you know, his most famous maxim, which appears in the sign of four, which was published in 1890, so the year after the murder of Mary Jane Kelly. And by that time, it's starting to seem, Jack the Ripper may have pulled off one final compounding stunt by vanishing into thin air. So this takes us back to the story. And I guess this is, to use another Sherlock Holmes aphorism, this is the curious incident to the dog in the nighttime, right? Because, you know, the dog does nothing in the nighttime famously.
剧透，但从我的描述方式来看，这很明显。嗯，正如福尔摩斯所说，当你排除了所有不可能的情况，剩下的，无论多么不可思议，都一定是真相。这就是他最著名的格言，出现在1890年出版的《四签名》中，也就是玛丽·简·凯利谋杀案发生后的第二年。到那时，情况开始看起来，开膛手杰克可能通过凭空消失完成了最后一次复杂的特技表演。所以这把我们带回了故事。我想这是，用另一句夏洛克·福尔摩斯的格言来说，这就是夜间狗的奇怪事件，对吧？因为，你知道，那条狗在夜间什么也没做，这是很有名的。
And you're waiting and waiting and waiting for the next Jack the Ripper murder. and it seems never to come. So there are patrols all winter and everybody is waiting, the newspapers are saying, you know, who will be next? How can it get worse after Mary Jane Kelly?
你一直在等待下一次开膛手杰克的谋杀案。但它似乎永远不会到来。所以整个冬天都有巡逻，每个人都在等待，报纸在说，你知道，下一个会是谁？在玛丽·简·凯利之后，情况还能怎么变坏？
But then there's nothing. Or is there? Because there are one or two crimes, aren't there, that possibly could be the Ripper? Yeah, so in the summer of 1889, a 40-year-old woman called Alice McKenzie is found in Spittal Fields
但后来什么都没有了。或者有吗？因为有一两起犯罪，不是吗，可能就是开膛手干的？是的，1889年夏天，一个名叫爱丽丝·麦肯齐的40岁妇女在斯皮塔佛德被发现，
with her throat cut and slashes to her abdomen. And although Dr. Phillips says no, this isn't the ripper, Dr. Bond, who gave the description of Mary Jane Kelly's mutilations that I read out, he thinks, yeah, it might be. Though I think if you look into it, Alice McKenzie, people think might have been killed by somebody who's left-handed rather than right-handed, smaller knife, and the stab wounds are much shallower, and the different, and the whole modus operandi is different. Yeah, and then there's February 1891, there's one final ripper scare when a young woman
喉咙被割开，腹部有刀伤。虽然菲利普斯医生说不，这不是开膛手干的，但邦德医生，他给出了我读过的玛丽·简·凯利肢解情况的描述，他认为，是的，可能是。虽然我认为如果你深入研究，爱丽丝·麦肯齐，人们认为可能是被一个左撇子而不是右撇子杀害的，刀更小，刺伤更浅，而且整个作案手法也不同。是的，然后是1891年2月，最后一次开膛手恐慌，当时一个年轻女子
called Francis Coles is found with her throat cut, although there are no mutilations to her body at all. And so I think the overwhelming balance of experts today, as it was at the time, is that neither Alice McKenzie nor Francis Coles were victims of Jack the Ripper, which means that the murder of Mary Jane Kelly was the kind of climactic horror, and then he vanishes. That's the thing I think that people find so baffling. Because, you know, serial killers normally continue. Why does he stop? Why does it never go anywhere after this? Well, I mean, it's fair to say that the police files, you know, they remain open. They're still open. And of course, the ambition of people to solve the murders, to put it mildly, has never abated.
名叫弗朗西斯·科尔斯被发现喉咙被割开，尽管她的身体没有任何肢解。所以我认为今天绝大多数专家，就像当时一样，认为爱丽丝·麦肯齐和弗朗西斯·科尔斯都不是开膛手杰克的受害者，这意味着玛丽·简·凯利的谋杀案是那种高潮式的恐怖，然后他就消失了。这就是我认为人们觉得如此令人困惑的事情。因为，你知道，连环杀手通常会继续作案。为什么他停下来了？为什么在这之后就再也没有下文了？嗯，我的意思是，公平地说，警方的档案，你知道，它们仍然是开放的。它们仍然是开放的。当然，人们破获谋杀案的野心，说得委婉一点，从未减弱。
And I think that in 2025, as in 1888, Jack the Ripper is this kind of nightmarish figure of legend still, kind of stalking people's fantasies and fears. but he also remains, you know, a standing temptation to amateur detectives to play homes and finally crack the case. Yeah, and of course, we'll be doing that ourselves, actually, so that will put that industry to bed because we'll be doing that in our next episode next week. If you're a rest of history club member, of course, you can discover who Jack the Ripper was right now. So the notoriety, I mean, it's obviously partly because it's not caught. But then there have been lots of unself murders before. Sure. It's partly because, as with so many of these stories, the figure of Jack the Ripper becomes the embodiment of something bigger, of the anxieties about class and poverty and migration and crime in the great metropolis, right? The world's greatest metropolis at this point. Yeah. And you've got the press. And the press is a huge part of this, isn't it? He's a media creation from the very beginning. You know, if that letter was a hoax,
我认为在2025年，就像在1888年一样，开膛手杰克仍然是这种噩梦般的传奇人物，仍然在跟踪人们的幻想和恐惧。但他仍然，你知道，是业余侦探扮演福尔摩斯并最终破案的持续诱惑。是的，当然，我们自己也会这样做，所以这会结束那个行业，因为我们将在下周的下一集中这样做。如果你是历史俱乐部会员，当然，你现在就可以发现开膛手杰克是谁。所以这种恶名，我的意思是，显然部分是因为他没有被抓住。但在此之前也有很多未破的谋杀案。当然。部分原因是，正如许多这些故事一样，开膛手杰克的形象成为了某种更大东西的化身，即对大都市中阶级、贫困、移民和犯罪的焦虑，对吧？当时世界上最伟大的大都市。是的。而且你有媒体。媒体是其中的重要组成部分，不是吗？他从一开始就是媒体的产物。你知道，如果那封信是恶作剧，
and if it was written by a journalist, then basically Jack the Ripper as a character is invented by the media to sell newspapers. Yeah, and I think there's one final explanation. He is the first modern serial killer. Presumably there must have been figures like him before, but they just weren't recognised as such. And it's telling, I think,
如果它是由记者写的，那么基本上开膛手杰克这个角色就是媒体为了卖报纸而发明的。是的，我认为还有一个最终的解释。他是第一个现代连环杀手。大概在他之前一定有像他这样的人物，但他们只是没有被这样识别出来。我认为这很能说明问题，
that even in the Sherlock Holmes stories, he's operating in a world where crimes are readily explicable, where there are discreet clues which you investigate and you find and you put them together and they reveal to you the motivation of the murderer and then you go and arrest the murderer. And this is how crime had been understood basically forever. So all the penny dreadfuls, you know, there are women being murdered by their jealous lovers in red barns and things like that. Or there are highwaymen who are holding people up or footpads or whatever. you know, sexual jealousy or greed or whatever, these are explicable motivations.
即使在夏洛克·福尔摩斯的故事中，他也在一个犯罪很容易解释的世界里运作，那里有离散的线索，你去调查，你发现它们，你把它们放在一起，它们向你揭示了凶手的动机，然后你去逮捕凶手。这就是犯罪基本上一直以来的理解方式。所以所有的廉价惊悚小说，你知道，有妇女在红谷仓被嫉妒的情人谋杀之类的故事。或者有拦路抢劫的人，或者扒手等等。你知道，性嫉妒或贪婪之类的，这些都是可以解释的动机。
The thing that people find so frightening about Jack the Ripper is there seems no motive to the crimes. And the police struggle with this, the press struggle with this, the general public struggle with this. Why is Jack the Ripper doing what he is doing? And it has to be said that there are a few people in London, those who are abreast of the latest scientific thinking that is emerging at this time in Germany, who are aware of perhaps a possible explanation for what Jack the Ripper is doing. And this is the fruit of a revolutionary development in the study of psychopathology, as it is called. The study of psychopaths, if you want to call it like that. And so that brings us back to W.T. Stead, because he is one of the people who is
人们觉得开膛手杰克最可怕的地方在于，这些罪行似乎毫无动机。警方对此感到困惑，媒体对此感到困惑，公众也对此感到困惑。开膛手杰克为什么要这样做？必须指出的是，当时伦敦有少数人，即那些了解德国当时新兴的最新科学思想的人，可能意识到了开膛手杰克行为的一种解释。这就是当时所谓的“精神病理学”革命性发展的成果。如果你愿意的话，可以称之为对精神病态者的研究。这又把我们带回了W.T.斯特德，因为他是了解这一切的人之一，不是吗？
aware of all this, isn't he? Yeah. And has basically said, I see the Ripper as being in a tradition of people, going back to actually somebody who've done on the rest of his history before, the Marquis de Sard. Correct. And by mentioning the Marquis de Sard, which he does in that same article where he also mentioned the Ripper as being a kind of Mr. Hyde figure, he's drawing on the work of one of the most distinguished representatives of this kind of new generation of pioneering psychiatrists
是的。他基本上说，我认为开膛手属于一类人，实际上可以追溯到他之前在《历史的其余部分》中提到过的人，即萨德侯爵。没错。通过提到萨德侯爵——他在同一篇文章中也提到了开膛手，称其为一种“海德先生”式的人物——他借鉴了这一代新兴先驱精神病学家中最杰出代表之一的研究成果，
that's emerged in Germany. This is a guy we talked about in relation to Oscar Wilde and the notion of homosexuality and heterosexuality. And it's a German called Richard von Krafft Ebbing. And Kraft Ebbing and his colleagues in Germany have begun to look at human sexuality as an expression of evolution and to explore it as a subject of scientific study. So rather than being something that should be judged in moral terms, you look at. can try and explain it in medical terms, in psychiatric terms. And Kraft Ebbing's own specialisation was what he called pathological fetishism. So essentially kind of deviancies from what he defined as the sexual norm.
这些研究成果出现在德国。这就是我们之前在讨论奥斯卡·王尔德以及同性恋和异性恋概念时提到的那个人。他是一位名叫理查德·冯·克拉夫特-埃宾的德国人。克拉夫特-埃宾和他在德国的同事们开始将人类性行为视为进化的表现，并将其作为科学研究的主题进行探索。因此，与其用道德标准来评判，不如尝试用医学术语、精神病学术语来解释它。克拉夫特-埃宾自己的专长是他所谓的“病理性恋物癖”。本质上就是偏离了他所定义的性规范的行为。
And in 1886, so only two years before Jack the Ripper, he published a vast compendium of basically sexual deviancy, sexual morbidities, he called it. psychopathia sexualis and you know people are very titillated by this it becomes very very famous which is presumably how stead would have come across it even before it ends up being translated into english in 1892 and it gives to the english language all kinds of words that we today I think take for granted so homosexuality is one heterosexuality is another there's also bisexuality crafty having coins that necrophilia masochism And psychopathia sexualist also introduces to Victorian Britain the concept of the counterpart of masochism, which is what Kraft Ebbing termed sadism.
1886年，也就是开膛手杰克出现的前两年，他出版了一部关于性变态、性病态的巨著，他称之为《性精神病态》。你知道，人们对此非常着迷，它变得非常非常出名，这大概就是斯特德在1892年它被翻译成英文之前接触到它的方式。它为英语贡献了各种各样的词汇，我认为我们今天已经习以为常了，比如“同性恋”是一个，“异性恋”是另一个，还有“双性恋”。克拉夫特-埃宾创造了这些词，还有“恋尸癖”、“受虐狂”。《性精神病态》还向维多利亚时代的英国介绍了受虐狂的对应概念，即克拉夫特-埃宾所称的“施虐狂”。
Yeah. So from the Marquis de Saad. And it was framed by Kraft Ebbing as an instinct, a sexual pathology that had always existed. So he wrote, that lust and cruelty frequently occur together is a fact that has long been recognized and not infrequently observed. and he defines the most sinister expression of this morbidity as being what he called lust murder and he defined it as lust potentiated as cruelty. And it's not surprising, I think,
是的。源自萨德侯爵。克拉夫特-埃宾将其定义为一种本能，一种一直存在的性病理。他写道：“欲望和残忍经常同时出现，这是一个早已被认识到且不时被观察到的事实。”他将这种病态最险恶的表现定义为他所谓的“欲望谋杀”，并将其定义为“被残忍所强化的欲望”。我认为这并不令人惊讶，
that he ends up obsessed by Jack the Ripper. And every time he revises the psychopathia sexualis, he includes ever more expansive descriptions of Jack the Ripper. And the Ripper ends up listed in the chapter on lust murder as case 17. and Kraft Ebbing writes about him, he does not seem to have had sexual intercourse with his victims, but very likely the murderous act and subsequent mutilation of the corpse were equivalents for the sexual act. So in other words, he's providing a motivation there. It may be true or not, but it is the kind of motivation that I think people in the 21st century
他最终沉迷于开膛手杰克。每次他修订《性精神病态》时，都会加入更多关于开膛手杰克的详尽描述。开膛手最终被列入“欲望谋杀”一章，作为第17个案例。克拉夫特-埃宾写道：“他似乎没有与受害者发生性关系，但很可能谋杀行为和随后的尸体损毁是性行为的替代品。”换句话说，他提供了一种动机。这可能是真的，也可能不是，但我认为这是21世纪的人们
listening to true crime podcasts or whatever would recognize as something plausible in a way that I think most people in the 1880s wouldn't. I agree with that completely, and I would say it seems to me as a product of the late 20th and 21st century is extremely implausible that there is no sexual dimension, even if it's unconscious in Jack the Ripper's crimes, the sort of frenzy of it, and also the attention given to the sexual organs of the victim suggests that there's something definitely going on there. Yeah, I think that this ultimately is why Jack the Ripper is commemorated as the first serial killer in history because it's not because he is the first person to commit kind of crimes like this. I can't believe that. It's because it's only in the 1880s that the motivations of murderers like Jack the Ripper first come to seem explicable by science, by psychiatry, by psychopathology. Or indeed, by top historians, Tom. Or by top historians, yes.
在听真实犯罪播客或其他内容时，会认为这是一种合理的方式，而我认为1880年代的大多数人不会这样认为。我完全同意这一点，而且作为20世纪末和21世纪的产物，我认为开膛手杰克的罪行中没有性维度是极其不可信的，即使是潜意识的。那种疯狂，以及对受害者性器官的关注，都表明其中肯定有什么东西。是的，我认为这最终就是为什么开膛手杰克被纪念为历史上第一个连环杀手的原因，并不是因为他是第一个犯下此类罪行的人。我无法相信这一点。而是因为直到1880年代，像开膛手杰克这样的杀手的动机才首次显得可以通过科学、精神病学、精神病理学来解释。或者确实，通过顶级历史学家，汤姆。或者通过顶级历史学家，是的。
That sets us up nicely for our final episode, Dominic, where we will be going through all the various lists of suspects that have been proposed and we will be revealing the truth, weren't we? So Tom, do you genuinely think you'll succeed where Inspector Abiline failed? I think I will. Wow. Well, that is exciting. I have a top theory.
这为我们的最后一集做了很好的铺垫，多米尼克，我们将梳理所有被提出的各种嫌疑人名单，我们将揭示真相，不是吗？那么汤姆，你真的认为你能成功，而阿伯莱恩探长失败了吗？我想我会的。哇。好吧，那太令人兴奋了。我有一个顶级理论。
I imagine listening to this. A lot of people cannot wait to hear that episode because there's been a lot of build-up, but finally next time we shall be revealing the identity of the Ripper. So if you are a member of the Restis History Club, you can hear it right now. If you can't wait and you'd like to join, then sign up at the Restis History.com. And with Christmas on the way, you can give that same delight to the history lover in your life. You can give them a full year's membership of The Rest is History Club. Theo tells me, it's the perfect gift for any history lover, or you can always drop a few hints and ask for it yourself. And this year, it comes
我想听众们一定迫不及待地想听那一集，因为已经做了很多铺垫，但下一次我们终于要揭开开膛手的身份了。所以，如果你是《历史的其余部分》俱乐部的成员，你现在就可以收听。如果你等不及了，想加入，请在therestisHistory.com注册。随着圣诞节的临近，你可以把你生活中的历史爱好者带来同样的快乐。你可以送他们一整年的《历史的其余部分》俱乐部会员资格。西奥告诉我，这对任何历史爱好者来说都是完美的礼物，或者你也可以总是暗示一下，自己要求一份。今年，它还
with an exclusive rest is history t-shirt designed in collaboration with our very own Theo Young-Smith who describes himself in the copy he's written
附赠一件独家的《历史的其余部分》T恤，这是与我们自己的西奥·杨-史密斯合作设计的，他在自己撰写的文案中形容自己
as a very stylish man. Not incorrectly, I think. So go to the rest ishistory.com and click on gifts. Obviously terms and conditions apply but nothing to medieval it says here so that's great banter. Well, on that bombshell
是一个非常时髦的男人。我想这没说错。所以去therestisHistory.com点击礼物。显然条款和条件适用，但这里说没有什么中世纪的内容，所以这真是个很棒的玩笑。好吧，带着这个重磅消息，
we should be back next time with the solution to a mystery that is perplexed. people for more than a century who was Jack the Ripper. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下期节目将回来，揭开困扰人们一个多世纪的谜团的答案：谁是开膛手杰克？再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。